ma cliente c'est en vidéo conférence et
semble en bonne santé ce sont les mots
de l'avocat bande-son de sushis
l'ancienne dirigeante birmane n'a plus
été vu depuis son arrestation le 1er
février dernier
cette dernière a été inculpé ce matin
pour avoir violé une loi sur les
télécommunications et pour incitation
aux troubles publics une actualité
judiciaire qui arrivent au lendemain
d'une manifestation particulièrement
meurtrières selon l'onu et 18 personnes
auraient été tuées par les militaires
lors de rassemblements dans les villes
de rangoun à mandalay dawei des
manifestants souvent conscients des
dangers lors de ces mobilisations
ils nous ont tiré dessus
hier et avant-hier je le sais mais je
m'en moque
j'ai déjà dit au revoir à ma famille
avant de quitter la maison
au cas où je ne pourrais pas revenir
malheureusement ils ont déjà échoué mais
ils ne veulent pas abandonner
il utilise toujours la force mais nous
continuons à nous battre et nous voulons
leur faire savoir que nous n'avons pas
peur d'eux et que nous ne reculons pas
des événements que le secrétaire général
des nations unies a tenu à dénoncer
je condamne fermement la répression
meurtrière en birmanie je demande
instamment à la communauté
internationale d'envoyer un signal clair
aux militaires pour qu'ils respectent la
volonté du peuple birman telle qu'elle a
été exprimée lors des élections et
mettre fin à la répression
le chef de la junte assure pourtant que
les autorités ont recours à un usage de
la force minimale contre les
rassemblements
une sortie qui n'empêche pas les états
unis et l'union européenne de prendre
des sanctions contre la birmanie
une initiative insuffisante selon le
rapporteur de l'onu qui encourage le
monde intensifié sa réponse depuis le
début des manifestations
une trentaine de personnes seraient
mortes dont un policier et plusieurs
journalistes ont été arrêtés